plenty of space makes the skoda octavia
scout station wagon a true family car
all-wheel drive makes it a great
off-roader - and gives it a more solid
safer feel and greatly improves traction
when it's needed the Scout stands three
centimeters higher than a regular
Octavia station wagon car tester van ho
Dyson offer recalls that Volkswagen took
over Skoda back in 1991 planning to
round out their model range at the lower
end with sturdy dependable and
affordable cars but some equipment
versions were reserved for VW s now
that's changed Skoda has come to stand
for comfortably spacious cars good
design and cutting edge assistance
systems this one for example has
radar-guided cruise control that
automatically maintains a safe distance
from the car ahead he says the Alcantara
leather seats give the interior a touch
of luxury while an intelligent light
assist make sure uncoming traffic isn't
blinded by your high beams at night the
interior leaves a generally good
impression the center console is tidy
trimmed in piano black and forms a
suitable frame for SCOTUS famous
infotainment system
[Music]
the three-spoke steering wheel lies
comfortably in the drivers hands as in
other Skoda models the instruments are
up-to-date and easy to read
[Music]
Skoda offers only one trim level for its
Octavia Scout station wagon the silver
colored underbody protection and back
and front gives it a robust off-roader
look Daskal title says the Octavia Scout
station wagon drives like a VW and would
be a good alternative to the gulf owl
track it's not only 12 centimeters
longer which amounts to more room from
both the backseat and the cargo space it
also lists for about 2,000 euros less
than the all track it's the gun on the
subject of cargo space this one provides
667 liters the taillights have the
c-shaped
typical of SCOTUS
the 2.6 8 meter wheelbase leaves enough
room inside for all occupants to ride in
comfort wherever they're sitting the
front has been completely redone the new
grille is quite a bit wider than its
predecessors the logo graces every
imaginable spot almost like an Eagle
Scouts collection of badges final points
out the Octavia Scouts
driving mode selectors a press of a
button tells the Scout whether it's on
regular pavement or it's very
comfortable for long hauls or on rough
terrain one gasoline-powered and three
diesel engines are available for this
counter our test car has the strongest
diesel coupled with a six-speed DSG
transmission it cuts a very decent
figure on rough terrain with its 135
kilowatt output and all-wheel drive with
a top speed of 219 km/h and an array of
safety systems it'll get you where
you're going swiftly and safely
[Music]
Duncan's notes like I note has two
points he would criticize one the
sat-nav takes some time getting booted
and to the suspension could be a bit
more comfortable but that's all
[Music]